I'm rapping this here hold on hold on
hold on wait wait wait hold on
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
so you know what you do this as well for
drugs all the time because there's
certain times I'll have an idea and I
think I'll remember that but then it's
like a bubble yup yeah gone are you like
what the [__] was that what was that
it's like God I'm like I was so good at
the moment so now I write things down
ideas bars
things so I I don't let me let me find
the cool one
and do we remember Kobe's come on
remember what Jack did remember what I
was like everybody
nobody looks back at them
I think it's like a right of passage I
got a rap I gotta Rap
God
[Music]
you gotta get Obama to do with you bro
you gotta get you gotta get 16 from
Obama bro because he's going through
what you went through which is like I've
achieved the Pinnacle of my profession
and when you're black and you do that
you go I need to drop it
okay
[Laughter]
if I didn't come you would have never
begun damn
[__]
do it again do it again do it again do
it again say it again
you would have never begun man oh my God
bro testify
[Music]
you would have never been gone hit the
verse
no to his point we don't remember Kobe
tacos they're not good nobody cares
hey I'm far away do I read it out loud
just say it out loud
it don't make sense
[Laughter]
hit us with a different one
was the origin story right now
it started exactly the scene has been
planted in his head yeah
wait this okay find a good one okay okay
okay a cross-eyed [__] double cross
mate
that's just starting
I'm a cross-eyed [__] double cross me I
make her I do the X like she cro all
right it's laying down
but the first the first the cross that
[__]
I just got it's like it's like you're
doing the the you ain't do your shows
like your spots also I just I'm
imagining this woman bro it's like you
you're the champ you gave her he knows
who it is wait hey the cross-eyed [__]
hold on Jeff
[Laughter]
[Music]
some of these you got to bring out the
press conference
[Music]
I'm gonna be there
hater bro this guy's [__] how come I
can't take the joke it's right there
we go into Toronto can you write him
better bars fantastic bro this is
fantastic
I know you know I know you know but
trust me I got bars
this line is actually funny
listen uh this is funny listen I don't
have time to date only got time to [__]
it's true
I'm not done yet I have time to date I
only got time to [__]
cause I come quick
that's bars
that's reasonable
sometimes as far as it's an excuse I
don't got time that's why and be like
that sometimes yeah you [__] for four
minutes
what's the point in [__] for long
yeah it's like cardio I already trained
today exactly
and when you came by the minute shout
out to Joe yeah
[Music]
they made it seem like his memory was
going bro what did you hear about that
what do you mean like he he was on some
show where he was like I got the gene
for Alzheimer's and then the media
caught on to it and they thought that
like he was already out really we go oh
P
let him call you let him cook I love you
let him cook he gonna go write some bars
right now act like he's nice we think
he's good at rapists
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not that's not the majority but
Africans do act bougie yeah it might be
an older thing might be I think yeah
yeah that's not the majority like now
the younger generation they're all
welcoming uh because the world's a whole
Melting Pot now you know what I mean the
internet done made that happen it
happens I remember when I was going to
college bro the way that people's
dressed in New York was so different in
the way that people dressed in
California like I could bring some [__]
to California and they never saw it in
their life like tips bro literally
they'd be like do you have a job
like they couldn't what about
construction yeah they couldn't fathom
and now no matter where we go even when
we go do shows everybody dresses the
same yeah everybody once you go to a
show and everyone got that haircut bro
it's gonna happen
it might be a little scary
I call it a jump fade did you jump fade
your boy what was his name
I I like to flex him he's worked for
everyone they pulled up he's right now
he's working with everyone Beyonce but
they pulled up like letting everybody
know that they yeah they're outside
they're the guys they're the guys so he
pulled me up with the suit last night
and even after oh you see me tonight no
uh you know I'm that guy like they ain't
seen it yet not everyone's seen my
outfit yet so I'll rock it twice I went
to the boxing bro bro if I paid five
thousand dollars for a coat I'm wearing
it five thousand not enough
thank you yeah baby I'm my Father's son
yeah that's the most Nigerian way to
ride one of the best parts of
documenting I don't give a [__] I'm
giving this away is when his parents are
given the the breakdown of the fighters
bro yeah oh yeah this was great
well it's right she's right though bro
she goes his strength what did she say
he's striking is not that precise
my dad and my mom they watch every UFC
fight card now and they'll watch every
middleweight even if they're not ranked
on that fight just uh and just trust
them out for me so when I have an
opponent
that was a big one excuse me I have an
opponent what'd that taste like bro
Smash Burgers
those are so good Oh I thought that was
the double entender from what happened
last night
that was smash no Burgers
allegedly all the Legends we should call
the whole podcast it's a hologram yeah
we're just making fun of what podcast is
I can't rap for [__]
Junior
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway
if we're clapping and stopping and
saying your name you either got a rap or
you got a double dutch that's facts bro
brain's ass media in the place to be
yeah okay Studio where to see oh boys
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was freestyle though
let's go yeah okay I do have one bar at
least I don't got bars bro yo Mark
hasn't spoken for the last 10 minutes
because he's been calculated
oh
[Music]
yeah he's been waiting for us hey hey
Mark do you have any Rhymes
[Laughter]
you got it you got it oh come on here we
go all right marks
all right let's go go go yo if you want
this I'll [__] you up like poeton oh you
want to get in the ring I'll make you my
whole gun oh okay it kind of right if
you put it but yeah a little bit a
little bit okay
keep going
we didn't forget about that
if you want to get it I'll [__] you like
Costa a Little Smoke on that pack like
I'm Rasta
[Applause]
the second one
bro
you need the impression without the
pressure it was s what the [__] was hola
gone so give me 10 minutes of not
talking
you was bringing too much attention
[Laughter]
nobody but like he popping Us in for the
next one
I'm rapping this year okay even if it
sucks I don't care I'm not trying to
make money off it I just want to express
I really I feel like I've got something
tonight
these are zins what is Zim's you never
had a Zen because look it's look I
thought it's gone oh no this is bad you
shouldn't have that hey leave me alone
it's legal it's legal yeah I'm look I'm
curious let me see nicotine pouch yeah I
don't do nicotine me neither well
[Laughter]
[Music]
honestly like the first disgusting hold
on
okay
[Music]
what's your thing
because I'm medium to find me finally
right find you let me find you okay I
like my gagging on
why'd you guys
what did I say what I'm just no you
don't want no they call me Mark gagganon
okay
because all these all these on my dick
and they
and they really want me to win y'all
didn't want me to Win Friends
the greatest African champ let's go baby
is the best